this video is brought to you by
brilliant problem solving based website
and app with a hands-on approach improve
your STEM skills while having a great
time learning a brilliant adored /by
graphics more on them into this who do
you think of when you hear the words
father of the atomic bomb we're guessing
it's Robert Oppenheimer the leader of
the Manhattan Project who famously
responded to the first a bomb test by
declaring now I am become death
destroyer of worlds but what if we told
you there was another contender a
scientist who came this close to making
the big breakthrough in 1934 a
breakthrough that could have resulted in
Nazi Germany developing the world's
first nuclear weapon the scientists who
almost created this terrifying
alternative reality was on Rico Fermi
The Godfather of the atom bomb a leading
light in both experimental and
theoretical physics Fermi was an almost
once-in-a-generation genius it was Fermi
who built the first operational nuclear
reactor in 1942 Fermi who created our
understanding of the subatomic particles
known today as fermions and Fermi who
helped Oppenheimer father the bomb from
fascist Italy to world war ii America
this is the life of on Rico Fermi the
greatest Italian scientist the side of
Galileo one of the themes we've touched
on time and again is that despite what
fiction tells you you usually can't tell
which child is gonna grow up to change
the world what I've on Bismarck for
example was lazy as a kid mathematician
any neither was going to be a language
teacher Johannes Kepler was obsessed
with joining the priesthood but there
are times when even real life follows
the rules of fiction times when you can
really just look at a child and think
that kid's gonna be world famous someday
Enrico Fermi it was one of those kids
born in Rome on September the 29th 1901
Fermi came from an average family his
father was a government railway
inspector while his mother Ida was a
teacher but idle was above
in one very particular way she believed
acquiring knowledge was an almost sacred
duty you might say that this was the
closest thing to religion in the Fermi
household unusually for the time the
family weren't Catholic and they sent
young Fermi to one of the few secular
schools in Rome their aged only six
family began to show signs of the genius
that he would become basically from the
moment he started school Fermi was
consistently at the top of his class Ida
had instilled in him a deep love for
math science and engineering and
everything else a brainy we're not
studying the boys spent his time
building electric motors with his older
brother oak we do so yes if he'd been
introduced child Fermi circa 1910 you'd
have probably thought to yourself it's
gonna be big but you might not have
guessed he'd be big in the world of
physics that's because it would take a
tragedy to set Fermi on that particular
path in January 1915 Fermi's brother
went into hospital for routine surgery
on a throat abscess something went wrong
and he died on the operating table
bleeding out at age only 15 for the
teenage Fermi this was like God had
cruelly hurled a lightning bolt right
into the middle of his life as a boy
Fermi had always been shy and
introverted but in the wake of Gilley's
death he became almost catatonic ly
withdrawn frightened Ida tried to
convince her son to lose himself in his
studies she found a 50 year old book on
physics and gave it to the boy to read
what Fermi read there blew his young
minds there was something about the
world described in that book that just
made sense to Fermi that made him want
to learn more from that point on the boy
wouldn't be a magpie leaping from one
stem subject to the next his mind would
instead be a high-powered laser focused
solely on physics in 1918 three years
after we Leo died Fermi applied to the
prestigious school a normal superior in
Pisa on November the 14th that yeah he
sat the entrance exam the task was to
write a competitive essay Fermi chose
the topic at characteristics of sounds
when the examiner read us in any fell
off his chair while anyone sitting this
exam was naturally intelligent Fermi was
at a whole different level it turns in a
paper that would have been impressive
for a doctoral thesis Fermi was
instantly fast-tracked on to this
doctoral program with his advisor the
director of the physics laboratory but
the director soon realized this kid was
such a natural that it was impossible to
teach him stuff in just three years of
self-study Fermi had become so good at
physics that he could run rings around a
department chair everybody at the school
could agree on one thing they couldn't
wait to see what he did next
[Music]
at the same time Fermi was rising
through the physics profession like an
out-of-control weather balloon another
Italian also found himself being
catapulted towards stardom on March the
23rd 1919 min months after Fermi Santa's
exam Benito Mussolini founded the
fascist party although neither firm
enormous Cellini could have known it at
the time their lives were destined to
cross in a way that would change history
within a year of the fascist parties
appearance chapters had sprung up across
the nation and whole regions descended
into violence Mussolini was a
world-class rabble rouser or a guy who
could whip up a mob in the time it takes
to boil an egg as his influence spreads
black shut militias began attacking
leftists burning down trade union
officers and physically stopping
left-wing officials from taking their
posts come July 1922 the whole of Italy
knew Mussolini's name and either loved
him or loathed him with one possible
exception all his life on Rico Fermi
would be staunchly apolitical never
showing the slightest hint of an
interest in politics as Italy fell into
chaos that summer he was likely thinking
of only one thing
defending his thesis by now Fermi had
already published his first couple of
papers and his planet-sized brain was
infamous across Pisa when he actually
came to defend his thesis before 11
examiner's it said only two of them were
capable of grasping what he was talking
about Fermi graduated with honors almost
immediately receiving a governmental
grants to continuous studies not the
government's would be around for much
longer though that same summer
Mussolini's black shirts smashed a
general strike called by Italian
leftists on October the 24th before a
gathering of 40,000 fascists ill duche
declared that the government was
incapable of governing and that his
party would physically remove it
power Mussolini's march on Rome was the
moment democracy died in Italy faced
with an insurrection the government
collapsed preferring fascism to anarchy
King Victor Emmanuel the third invited
Mussolini to form a new governments on
Halloween that year a fitting days if
there ever was one Italy's Balder fatter
version of Hitler became Prime Minister
the first fascist leader in history but
while life was about to take a bad turn
for easily in general it was taking a
series of extremely good turns friend
Rico Fermi between 1922 and 1926 Fermi
won a series of scholarships going
abroad to teach in Germany in the
Netherlands by the time he settles back
in Italy in 1926 he was ready to change
the world offered the chair of
theoretical physics at the University of
Rome aged just 25 Fermi made
breakthrough after breakthrough perhaps
his most lasting was the developments of
what are known as Fermi Dirac statistics
basically a way of understanding a group
of subatomic particles that would
otherwise make us go what
every time we thought about them in fact
Fermi it was so prolific and it's
intuition so often accurate that his
colleagues started calling him the Pope
of physics but it wasn't just Fermi's
colleagues who were paying attention to
his extraordinary minds in 1929 Benito
Mussolini now absolute dictator of Italy
personally appointed Fermi to the
accademia dei lincei
the apolitical physicist was given a
huge salary a uniform to wear and the
title of excellency all he had to do in
return was bring glory upon Mussolini's
Italy by making more breakthroughs
scarily well that's what happened next
in his new post Fermi would soon come
terrifyingly close to giving ill duche
the key to the atom bomb
[Music]
the next few years were crazy busy for
Fahmy in 1928 he married Laura cap on a
daughter of a respected Jewish family
with him adapt to children in 1930 he
made his first visit to America where he
lectured on quantum theory
shortly after Fermi seems to have
decided the quantum field was becoming
exhausted he switched his focus to
nuclear physics it was this switch that
would lead to his big breakthrough in
1934 Fermi and his team were researching
the atom that already discovered that
pretty much every element is capable of
nuclear transformation and we're now
focusing on uranium it was while working
with the elements that firmly discovered
the first step toward nuclear fission
since we're a History Channel rather
than a science Channel were not
qualified to go deep into this but the
basic gist is that Fermi made a
breakthrough from which any
garden-variety genius could have deduced
other breakthroughs could be made
eventually leading to everything from
nuclear reactors to atomic bombs as the
2016 book the Pope of physics notes had
Fermi's brain been firing on all
cylinders at that time it's likely
nuclear fission would have been
discovered in Italy in 1935 on possible
consequence is that Nazi Germany would
have used that research to acquire
nuclear weapons it's a scary thought
that out there just a few degrees away
sits a parallel universe where the
London Blitz was not a sustained
campaign but a single bomb falling from
the sky that turns the British capital
into rubble in a flash of light luckily
though we don't live in that universe in
our universe Fermi's brain for some
reason wasn't quite operating at full
capacity he merely thought it created a
new element one the press argued should
be named after Mussolini by the time
everyone figured out what was actually
going on and he had started Nazi Germany
could have got on the bomb was gone
in terms of near misses they don't get
much nearer than that still Fermi's work
was important important enough to him to
be awarded the Nobel Prize in Physics in
1938 and that's today's second stroke of
good luck because 1938 was when
everything went to hell that summer
Mussolini suddenly brought in a raft of
anti-jewish laws so extreme were these
laws so nakedly models on hitler's
they penetrated even Fermi's physics
adult mind although he was staunchly
apolitical fermions ignore the fact that
these new laws targeted his wife and
probably their children unfortunately
the new laws also made it impossible for
Jews to leave Italy without a very good
reason a reason like well perhaps
winning the Nobel Prize that December
Fermi traveled to Sweden to collect his
Nobel Prize for Physics he took his
family with him the no travel laws for
Jews briefly waved on the understanding
that the award would bring glory
honestly in Stockholm Fermi accepted his
award then used his prize money to get
himself his wife and his children on a
boat to the USA and that's how Italy's
greatest modern scientist came to leave
his country behind for good it's curious
to think that had Mussolini not suddenly
passed those anti-jewish laws Fermi
would have likely stayed in Italy for
the duration of the war all the way I
could do under Oppenheimer would be lost
lost too would be the world's first
nuclear reactor soon to be built under
Fermi's watch in Chicago and Fermi was
just one of thousands of scientists who
led the continent in those days had
Europe's fascists not become so obsessed
with the national purity their nations
would Ron eclis have lasted much longer
On January the 2nd 1939 the Fermi's
arrived in New York City for the rest of
their lives that call America home now
just poor we continue today I hope then
you are not gonna be developing any
nuclear bombs but if you'd like to get a
better grasp on physics but let me tell
you about brilliance brilliant is a
problem-solving based website and zapped
with a hands-on approach they've got
over 60 interactive courses in maths
science and computer science now you've
heard me talk about brilliant before on
this channel they teach you about those
subjects I mentioned but beyond that
they also teach you problem-solving
skills which are practical even if you
don't pursue the sciences learning how
to break down complex problems to their
component parts is pretty critical in
whatever career path you choose or maybe
you've wanted to learn program that
you've always been a bit daunted but
normally it requires you to learn the
tedious details of a specific
programming language but really the
bedrock of it is understanding the fun
mental algorithms are brilliant you
start by programming a drone with simple
instructions which teaches you the basic
structure of every program you'll ever
write it's all drag-and-drop exercises
which will get you thinking like your
computer scientist in no time and that's
just one example
there's loads of great stuff brilliance
is a great compliment to watching videos
like this one and it will really help
you master even complex technical
subjects so if you want to support by
graphics and get unlimited access to all
of brilliance in-depth maths and science
courses please head over to brilliant
org forward slash bar graphics and
you'll get 20% of their annual premium
subscription and let's go back to the
video
[Music]
barely had Fermi set foot inside
Columbia that he was already gifting his
new government breakthroughs that same
spring 1939 the Italian and his team
showed that emitting neutrons into
uranium was the process of fission that
could trigger a chain reaction in other
words kaboom
by March the University was already
writing to the Navy suggesting that this
could be used as a weapon nor was Fermi
himself blind to this possibility one
day in a Manhattan high-rise he glanced
out a window at the bustling city and
murmured little bomb like that and it
would all disappear but Fermi was no
Oppenheimer tortured inside by the
destruction his research could wreak he
actually went to Washington DC to
personally try and drum up funding for
nuclear weapons research but his
presentation was so singularly
uncharismatic
that he walked away with only the
smallest of grants it wasn't until
Albert Einstein personally wrote to
Franklin D Roosevelt about the potential
for superweapons that the American
government began to really show some
interest still it was slow progress only
on December the 6th 1941 was a project
to study these theories in Chicago
signed off on but if things had been
moving slowly for Fermi's research up
until that point they were about to gain
a sense of extreme urgency so you
probably are in the history class you
know what happens on December the 7th
1941 the Japanese bombing of Pearl
Harbor dragged America kicking and
screaming into the war it also had the
side effects that every Italian in the
country was immediately classed as an
enemy alien and subjected to severe
travel restrictions it took nearly six
months for Fermi's restrictions to be
waved for his research he finally
arrived in Chicago in summer 1942 but
once he was there Fermi almost
immediately proved his worth we already
spoke of one terrifying parallel
universe where the axis got the bomb now
we're going to speak about a much
weirder one the universe where this
video is entitled Enrico Fermi The
Godfather of the atomic bomb but Enrico
Fermi the mad scientist who destroyed
Chicago Fermi and his team assembled a
nuclear reactor on the squash court of
the University of Chicago towards the
end of 1942 on December the 2nd they
sent it critical as the New York Times
later wrote of the potentially dangerous
it's the only safeguards against an
uncontrolled atomic chain reaction that
would have irradiated a significant part
of Chicago was a scientist wielding an
axe to cut the rope that held an
emergency control rod suspended from the
balcony and a few other brave volunteers
whose job was to douse the runaway
reactor with buckets of
neutron-absorbing KDM sulfate Fermi
actually jokes that if the reactor went
out of control the assembled team should
run and hide behind a big hill many
miles away but of course Chicago pile 1
didn't become Chernobyl before Chernobyl
it worked
creating a self-sustaining atomic chain
reaction the first working nuclear
reactor in history shortly after a code
was broadcast to Washington DC the
Italian navigator has just landed in the
New World and that's was the dawn of the
Atomic Age and it was also the dawn of a
new age in Fermi's work in 1944 the
Italian physicist became a naturalized
US citizen shortly after he was sent
down to Los Alamos to work on the
manhattan project under robert
Oppenheimer Fermi was actually there on
July the 16th 1945 when the first
plutonium bomb was tested at the
infamous Trinity test in Alamogordo New
Mexico this was the moment when
Oppenheimer assuming the power he had
unleashed thought the phrase but as
we've said before Fermi was no
Oppenheimer faced with the reality of
the weapon capable of wiping out entire
cities in the blink of an eye Fermi only
noted that the Trinity test was a labor
of considerable scientific interest
in the last month's of the Manhattan
Project Fermi's dedication to building
the bomb did not waver although in April
he noted that their Labor's would one
day be able to be reproduced by smaller
nations or even groups he still thought
it a worthwhile endeavor that June he
joined the scientific panel of the
engineering committee a group tasked in
part with advising on the use of atomic
weapons against Japan
just like his colleagues Fermi advocated
for an atomic strike although some
members of the panel did object on
ethical grounds preferring instead a
public test that would give Japan
warning President Harry Truman signed
off on the attack just two months later
on August the 6th 1945 a bomb distilled
from the work of Fermi Oppenheimer and
the other geniuses at Los Alamos was
loaded onto the Enola Gay and flown off
into the night sky six hours later the
Enola gays bomb bay doors opened above
the commercial lens military city of
Hiroshima little boy dropped 444 seconds
at the end of that time the world
changed forever
the first atomic bomb ever used in
warfare was detonated at precisely 16
minutes and 2 seconds past 8:00 in the
morning some 609 meters above Hiroshima
within 0.1 of a second the air over the
city center had reached two hundred and
seventy seven thousand seven hundred and
sixty degrees Celsius a woman sat nearly
a kilometer away on the banks of the
city's river was instantly vaporized as
the fireball expanded granite stones
melted the internal organs of humans and
animals vaporized and exposed skin was
simply burned off by the time a single
second had passed a blast way of
traveling 1,500 kilometers an hour had
torn the clothes of nearly everyone in
the city destroyed 60,000 buildings and
an intense firestorm had started that
would rage the hours and hours in that
instant 80,000 people died including up
to 20,000 Korean slave laborers and over
a dozen Allied POWs many tens of
thousands would die of radiation
poisoning over the coming weeks it was
carnage on a previously unimaginable
scale and it wasn't over three days
later on August the ninth another plane
carrying another bomb flew over Japan
originally it was meant to drop its
payload on the ancient city of kakora
but
thick cloud meant that Nagasaki became
its target at 11:02 a.m. fat man
exploded above the port city turning
40,000 people into ash
it was the second and today's the last
time atomic weapons have been used in
warfare six days later Japan surrendered
unconditionally today it remains up the
debate whether the real motivation for
Japanese surrender was the two atomic
bombs or the USSR's declaration of war
on the same day as Nagasaki whatever the
truth there's no denying that the
weapons Fermi helps build had just
shocked the world by now though the war
was already over in Europe in Italy
partisans had captured Mussolini
stringing up his corpse in a Milan
square Hitler too was dead killed by a
self-inflicted gunshot in his Fuehrer
bunker the fascists who chased Fermi and
his family out of Europe were gone the
physicist could now go back to his home
country whenever he chose but what
remains in Italy for him his wife's
family were killed in the Holocaust Rome
lay in ruins instead in fall of 1945
Fermi accepted a teaching position at
the University of Chicago he would live
in that city for the rest of his life
[Music]
the last year's of Enrico Fermi's life
were marked by returns the magpie like
fascination that characterized his
earlier years at Chicago he moved on
from nuclear physics and began
researching elementary particles before
becoming obsessed with cosmic rays
perhaps his most famous contribution to
science in this time though came not in
the form of a discovery but of a
question where is everybody
in 1950 Fermi was lunching with some
colleagues when they began to discuss
alien civilizations it was three years
after the supposed Roswell crash a time
when UFOs were all the rage one by one
Fermi's friends asserted that they were
undoubtedly aliens out there in the
galaxy it was at this point Fermi asked
his question where is everybody may
sound like a flip remark but Fermi had a
serious point he had realized that given
the immense age of the galaxy any
civilization with even the most
rudimentary rocket technology should
colonized it by now assuming even a
hyper conservative estimate for how
often an intelligent civilization arises
the shear time scales involved
meant there should be abundant evidence
of aliens by now so again where is
everyone
today that simple question is known as
the Fermi paradox and the list of
explanations as to why there are no
signs of alien life could fill a dozen
videos all by themselves seriously if
you want to go down an infinite click
all just types of the great filter or
dark forest theory into Google
but while Fermi may have meddled in many
disciplines in his later years he could
never quite escape the one running
thread throughout his working life
nuclear physics in 1949 Fermi joins the
general Advisory Committee to the Atomic
Energy Commission that year the USSR had
tested its first atomic weapon and the
committee had gathered to decide on the
practical and moral implications of the
USA developing thermonuclear devices
unlike the atomic bombing of Japan Fermi
was steadfastly against the idea a
hydrogen bomb he wrote in a dissension
from the majority opinion becomes a
weapon which in practical effect is
almost one of genocide it is necessarily
an evil thing considered in any light
after a lifetime with no political
opinions at all it seemed Enrico Fermi
was finally waking up to a world where
governments might use his discoveries
for evil but this new mindset it only
went so far when Truman signed off on
the h-bomb Fermi dutifully went back to
Los Alamos to work on it it is said he
hopes to prove such a weapon was
impossible if that's the case but he was
doomed to disappointment the world's
first hydrogen bomb was tested in the
Marshall Islands on of them the first
1952 the explosion was so vast so
world-changing in its implications that
it graced the cover of time not long
after that Fermi came up with his own
pessimistic answer to the Fermi paradox
there were no alien civilizations
because they'd all wipe themselves out
with thermonuclear weapons still Fermi
being funny he carried on working there
were doubtless more discoveries out
there to be made in the summer of 1954
even went back to Italy hiking in the
mountains and enjoying the air of the
old country at least that was his plan
the reality was Fermi found himself
feeling constantly rundown when he
returns to Chicago at the end of his
vacation he went straight to the doctor
since you can already see we're nearing
the end of this video you can probably
guess what came next the doctors told
Fermi he had stomach cancer although
they tried to cure it the disease was
already far too advanced on Rico Fermi
died on November the 28th 1954 it was 53
today Fermi's name lives on most notably
in the paradox named after him and the
element fermium discovered in 1953 while
it's doubtful the average Joe has heard
of him he remains a highly respected
genius who still gets his due yet it's
interesting to recall just how unlikely
this great reputation was if things had
been just a shade different Fermi could
have gone down in history as the man who
accidentally gave the axis the bomb or
he could have become trapped in Italy in
1938 and perished alongside his wife in
the Holocaust he may have even made it
to America only to send Chicago pile one
out of control and call as the world's
first nuclear meltdown thankfully this
universe is one where disaster never
struck where Fermi's genius helped shape
the world rather than end it he may have
lived a relatively short life but Fermi
did enough work in his five decades to
fill hundreds of lifetime's so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do smash that thumbs up
button below and don't forget to
subscribe also do support this channel
and check out our fantastic sponsor
brilliance who I'm linking to below and
thank you for watching